CONGRESSIONAL DEMS WERE DOING
INSTEAD OF LEGISLATING THIS
WEEK.
BUT FIRST --
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BAHR
SITTING DOWN WITH A WIDE-RANGING
INTERVIEW WITH FOX NEWS EARLIER
TODAY AND IT'S DRIVING THE
CRITICS NUTS.
>> ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BAHR
SHORT ON SPECIFICS, LONG ON
RHETORIC TODAY.
>> THIS ATTORNEY GENERAL IS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S FANTASIES.
>> HE ACTS MORE AND MORE LIKE A
MOUTHPIECE OF THE PRESIDENT.
IT'S MORE THAN DISAPPOINTING.
>> ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE.
BAHR HAS DONE NOTHING BUT DAMAGE
HIS CREDIBILITY.
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> HE MIGHT AS WELL --
>> GOOD LORD.
>> SLAP AN EX-KGB BAG ON OUR
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> DISGUSTING.
WHAT IS BAHR ACTUALLY SAY,
THOUGH, THAT WAS SO
CONTROVERSIAL.
WELL, NOT A WHOLE LOT.
HE DID PREVIEW HOW THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
INVESTIGATORS MIGHT PLAY OUT.
AND WHY.
WELL, LET'S UNPACK EACH OF THE
SIGNIFICANT TAKEAWAYS
ONE-BY-ONE.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF YOU
TONIGHT TO UNDERSTAND EVERY BIT
OF THIS.
FIRST.
HERE'S WHY BAR INITIATED THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> NO ONE HAS REALLY LOOKED AT
IT.
I THINK THERE'S A MISCONCEPTION
OUT THERE THAT WE KNOW A LOT
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS, BOB
MUELLER DID NOT LOOK AT THE
GOVERNMENT'S ACTIVITIES, HE'S
LOOKING AT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
HAD CONSPIRED WITH THE RUSSIANS.
HE WAS NOT GOING BACK TO LOOK AT
THE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE PROGRAM.
>> Laura: SECOND, THE A.G.
REVEALS THE MORE HE DIG, THE
MORE QUESTIONS HE HAS.
>> I TRIED TO GET THE QUESTIONS.
A LOT OF THE ANSWERS ARE
INADEQUATE.
AND I ALSO FOUND THAT SOME OF
THE EXPLANATIONS THAT I'VE
GOTTEN DON'T HANG TOGETHER.
SO, IN A SENSE, I HAVE MORE
QUESTIONS TODAY THAN I DID WHEN
I FIRST STARTED.
>> Laura: HE ALSO EXPLAINED WHY
THE NATURE OF THE PLAYERS BEHIND
THIS CAMPAIGN TO SPY ON TRUMP
WAS UNUSUAL.
EVEN TO A SEASONED VET LIKE
BAHR.
>> THIS WAS HANDLED AT A SENIOR
LEVEL OF THE DEPARTMENTS, NOT IN
THE ORDINARY WAY THAT
INVESTIGATIONS OR
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE ACTIVITIES
ARE CONDUCTED.
IT WAS AN AD HOC SMALL GROUP,
MOST OF THE PEOPLE ARE NOT WITH
THE FBI OR CIA OR THE OTHER
AGENCIES INVOLVED.
>> Laura: BAHR REVEALED WHY IT'S
IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST THAT HE
PURSUE POTENTIALLY THE CORRUPT
ORIGINS OF THE RUSSIAN PROBE.
>> IF WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT
FOREIGN INFLUENCE FOR THE SAME
REASON, WE SHOULD BE WORRIED
ABOUT WHETHER GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS ABUSED THEIR POWER AND
PUT THEIR THUMB ON THE SCALE.
AND SO I'M NOT SAYING THAT
HAPPENED, BUT I'M SAYING WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT THAT.
>> Laura: BINGO.
NOW GIVEN THE CHALLENGES,
SOMEONE OF BILL BAHR'S STATURE
COULD WEATHER THE ATTACKS AND
ACTUALLY REMAIN EFFECTIVE.
>> WHEN YOU TOOK THIS JOB, DID
YOU THINK THAT DEMOCRATS WOULD
MAKE YOU THE TARGET?
>> YES.
>> YOU WERE READY FOR THAT.
>> YES, I THOUGHT I WAS IN A
POSITION WHERE THIS KIND OF
CRITICISM REALLY WOULDN'T BOTHER
ME VERY MUCH.
>> Laura: HE'S COMPLETELY NOT